I am always
um
I always point out to all my friends
like you should consider getting off
birth control right because birth
control is designed to disrupt women's
hormones so that's also true of plastic
that's true of a lot of things that we
celebrate we get excited about but we
ultimately find out later maybe we
shouldn't have as much of this uh we are
a society that when we have an
innovation we tend to be like it's great
use it everywhere and then later decades
later we're like oh perhaps not but
there are some things we're not allowed
to question so again for me the big one
that I always say to women is birth
control you should question birth
control I know for some people it's a
good thing and it can be helpful but
generally long-term birth control use is
uh there's a study that's out right now
which got published by Cambridge
University press women who start birth
control under the age of 20. so as
teenagers have are 130 more likely to
develop depression than women who do not
and then all women who start birth
control have higher rates of depression
than women who do not